Kenya's appeal court has ruled that a
government plan to raise taxes will go
ahead the finance law sparked Nationwide
protests supported by the opposition at
least 30 people have been killed this
month the measures were suspended by the
high court but that's now been overruled
the law will double tax on fuel and also
introduce a housing Levy well let's go
straight to our correspondent Malcolm
Webb he joins us from the capital
Nairobi Malcolm this is a contentious
decision by the court talk us through
the thinking here
appeals court as well
as ruled and go ahead and collect these
uh these increased taxes which as you
mentioned include doubling the tax on
fuel a housing Levy that will be uh
taxed on all earners in the formal
sector across the board the taxes have
been criticized uh for being regressive
and the political opposition uh said
this is exactly what they've been
protesting against and objecting to in
recent weeks now Kenya is struggling uh
to keep up with its debt repayments the
Kenya Shilling has been growing weak
against the dollar so the cost of those
loans has been going up Kenya had to
seek loans from the international
monetary fund the international lender
of Last Resort earlier this year and so
the government says it needs to raise
more Revenue to be able to keep up with
its Financial Obligations still though
Malcolm this is presumably not going to
be a very popular decision are you
already hearing calls to take back to
the streets
well there were protests last week and
violence as they were broken up by
police and was the opposition said
there's a brutal Crackdown using
excessive force the word that had been
protests planned for this week but they
called them off and instead uh called
for a vigil in memory of those people
who'd been killed in the violence uh the
week before President William Ruto and
opposition leader raila odinga both said
that they were willing to sit down and
talk but people were waiting to see if
that will actually happen and people are
also waiting to see what the
opposition's reaction will be to this
Court ruling and if indeed they will
call their supporters back to the
streets we'll continue following that
very closely here on altazira Malcolm
Webb there for us in the Kenyan Capital
Nairobi thanks Matthew